nearly a dozen high school graduates  accepting apprenticeships at tesla today  it is called  signing day at valley high school a  partnership with tesla where students  take classes that get them certified in  automation and robotics while they're  doing  an apprenticeship at the factory in  northern nevada aidan mckenna  was one of the 11 students accepting  them today and says he's so excited to  start his  new life those are some bright young men  and women  and really future people that will make  a big impact in america's future right  yeah and a wonderful opportunity you  know let's keep them in our state as  well  good night